你在股市裡
賺到的每一塊錢
都是從別人口袋裡
掏出來的
你有沒有想過
那個人是誰
大多數人對投資的理解
就四個字
低買高賣
但這四個字的背後
蘊藏一個
所有人都在迴避的問題
你買入的時候
誰在賣給你
你賣出的時候
誰接手了你的股票
更重要的是
憑什麼你覺得自己
比對面那個人聰明
投資賺錢
從來不是
選對了某一檔股票
這麼簡單
它的底層
是一場關於
資訊 時間 跟風險的
三方博弈
而這場博弈裡的錢
只有三種來源
如果你搞不清楚
自己賺的是哪一種
你就不是賺錢的人
這部影片
不講那種
長期持有的正確廢話
我要透過幾個
真實發生在台股的故事
把投資賺錢的底層機制
一層一層
拆開給你看
看完你會明白
為什麼
有人在同一個股市裡
年年賺錢
而另一群人
用同樣的資訊
卻年年虧損
有一句話
是這樣說的
你永遠賺不到
認知以外的錢
而這部影片
我會把
投資賺錢的核心
刻進你的認知裡
我是小王子
20年股票實戰交易員
靠股票當沖跟波段
連續五年獲利破千萬
我會用你
聽得懂的語言
幫你看透股市裡
沒有人願意說出的
底層邏輯
台股裡的錢
說到底
其實就是三種來源
這三種
你都能合法的取得
只是殘酷的現實是
大多數人以為
自己在賺
第一種跟第三種
但實際上
你反而是
其中一種來源
被其他人賺走錢
接下來
就讓我們一起
看穿這三種來源
背後的真相
第一種來源
是最乾淨的錢
也是最難賺到的錢
它叫做價值創造
什麼是價值創造
就是一家公司
去年賺了10億
今年賺了20億
多出來這10億
這10億
不是從別人那裡搶來的
是這家公司
努力經營
真金白銀創造出來的
而你持有
這家公司的股份
你擁有公司的一部分
公司成長
你分到一杯羹
就這麼簡單
這種錢
有一個很特別的地方
它跟你對手的想法無關
跟K線圖也無關
甚至跟你
買入的時機
關係也不大
它只取決於一件事
這家企業
有沒有在創造
真實的利潤
我來說一個
很多台灣人
天天接觸
但從來沒有想過
要投資它的公司
統一超商
也就是我們熟悉的
7-ELEVEN
這家公司
沒有AI題材
沒有爆炸性的成長故事
你應該沒看過
財經新聞報導它
但你去翻它
過去20年的營收
你會發現一件
很無聊的事情
它就是年復一年
開更多門市
賣更多東西
把觸角伸到更多通路
獲利就是
無聊的慢慢的
穩定成長
如果你在20年前
買進統一超商
一路抱著
你賺到的
不是那種
新聞會爆出來的
暴漲價差
你賺到的是
這家公司
替你創造出來的
真實價值
為什麼最難賺
因為它需要你做一件
很多人做不到的事
你必須真的了解
這家公司在做什麼
公司未來有沒有前景？
這個產業會不會沒落
這沒有人說得準
沒有人知道
未來會長什麼樣子
更何況
你必須抱得住股票
當別人在談論
他們買的股票
最近三個月
翻了一倍兩倍
而你看看手上的股票
等了三年
也才翻一倍
你還有信心
自己能夠抱著那支
慢吞吞的股票嗎
大多數人會怎麼做
他們拿著長期投資的觀念
做著短期交易的行為
最後呢
長的沒有賺到
短的賠光了錢
第二種來源
是股市裡
流動最快的錢
也是最危險的錢
它叫做
情緒溢價
情緒溢價的邏輯
是這樣的
公司本身的營運狀況
沒有發生任何變化
但因為股市裡的投資人
集體陷入
恐懼或是貪婪
價格就會出現了
劇烈的波動
而股價的低點
往往是投資人
最恐懼的時刻
股價的高點
則是投資人
最狂熱的時候
所以說
你要在
別人恐慌的時候
勇敢買進
在別人狂熱的時候
搶先賣出
賺的就是這份
情緒差價
聽起來很簡單
但問題來了
你怎麼確定
恐慌的是別人
不是你自己
我來分享一個
所有台股投資人
都記得的案例
2025年4月
川普宣佈對等關稅政策
消息一出
全球股市劇烈震盪
台灣90%以上的股票
全體大崩跌
不管是新聞
還是任何一個
股市的討論區
全都是一片哀嚎
所有人都在說
這次真的不一樣
台股要崩了
投資人陷入
前所未有的恐慌
搶著趕快賣出股票
但是
就在同一個時間點
股市裡有另外一批人
默默的買進了那些
大家搶著賣出的股票
幾天後
股市大反彈
這些人也成功
買在股價的低點
而這些股票
就是你最恐慌的時候
親手賣給他們的
每次台股大跌
都會上演
同樣的劇本
但下次再遇到
你真的敢買嗎
你怎麼知道
後面還會不會再跌？
現在就是低點？
真正賺到情緒溢價的人
他沒有什麼
超強的預知能力
搞不好他對股市
根本不了解
他只是有一顆
別人沒有的心髒
在所有人
陷入恐慌的時候
他卻最貪婪
而大多數投資人
幾乎每次都
站在錯的那一邊
因為那個時候
繼續持有
感覺像是在
欺騙自己
停損出場
反而才像是
唯一理性的選擇
這就是情緒溢價
最殘酷的地方
這筆錢
是從你以為自己
在做正確決定的
那個瞬間
開始流失的
第三個來源
是最隱蔽的錢
但也是邏輯上
最清晰的錢
它的名字叫做
風險補償
風險補償的意思是
你承擔了別人
不願意承擔的風險
就有機會賺到
別人賺不到的錢
最好理解的例子
就是保險公司
他們做的事情
就是接下
別人不想要的風險
然後收取對應的保費
大多數時候
他收保費賺錢
偶爾發生
大型意外事件
他才要賠一大筆
但只要他定價精準
做好風險分散
長期下來
公司就是能賺錢
股市裡也有
完全一樣的邏輯
最常見的案例
就是當沖
台灣90%投資人
聽到當沖兩個字
第一個想法就是
危險
不可否認
十個人做當沖
有九個都在賠錢
當沖
確實是一個
風險比較大的
投資方式
但你反過來想
那九個當沖賠錢的人
把錢賠給誰了？
當然是賠給
那唯一一個
當沖賺錢的人
這就是風險
背後隱藏的機會
但你怎麼知道
你是不是
那10%賺錢的人呢？
你思考一下
前面保險公司的例子
保險公司是怎麼賺到錢的？
他們利用
其他人的不安全感
主動承擔風險
制定一個
賺大於賠的機制
做當沖
你完全能用
一樣的方法
利用那90%
當沖客的不安全感
制定一套
長期下來
賺大於賠的模式
這就是
剩下的10%人
當沖賺錢的
最大祕密
也就是
風險補償的本質
不是要你去冒險
而是去承擔那些
有合理補償
但別人因為各種原因
無法承擔的風險
聽到這裡
你可能會覺得有點沮喪
想賺價值創造
但你看不出
哪間公司
能真正穩定成長
想賺情緒溢價
卻沒有那個心臟
抵抗恐懼的本能
想賺風險補償
你卻不敢承擔
大家都在躲的風險
但我必須告訴你一件事
我們這些
本金不多的投資人
手上其實握著
一張王牌
而我們大多數人
正在親手
把它丟進垃圾桶
這張王牌
叫做時間壓力
全球頂尖的
資產管理機構
掌管著幾兆美元的資金
他們的經理人
每年都要接受4次
業績審查
如果連續兩季
績效都不好
他們的客戶
就會要求他們退錢
如果連續四季都很差
經理人直接被換掉
假如你發現了一個
當沖的方法
有機會在三年之內
讓你的資產
翻好幾倍
你可以先拿一點點錢
測試個半年一年
實證這個方法
到底行不行
適不適合你
但這些機構不行
他們必須
對顧客負責
他們付不起這個成本
也沒有時間試錯
他們不可能
先告訴客戶
我還在測試一個方法
再給我一年的時間
時間到了
他們就得繳交
優異的成績單
但你不用
你不需要向任何人
交代你賺多少
你不會因為
暫時的虧損
以後被禁止進入股市
你可以在
景氣最差的時候
休息什麼都不做
也不會有人責怪你
可惜的是
大多數人
並沒有把握這個優勢
真正決定
你是否能致富的是
你如何善用優勢
這件事情
會指向一個
讓多數人
不舒服的真相
幾乎所有人
都高估了自己的
判斷能力
大部分人
對投資賺錢的想像
是這樣的
判斷股價
接下來是漲還是跌
提前佈局
坐等兌現
但你去看那些
真正靠投資
累積了大量財富的人
你會發現一個
非常反常識的共性
他們幾乎不做
精確預測
橡樹資本的創辦人
霍華德馬克斯
管理著將近
兩兆台幣規模的資產
他有一句話
被整個投資界
反覆引用
我們從不試圖預測未來
我們只評估
當下的賠率
夠不夠好
這句話濃縮了
投資賺錢最底層的
思維模型
叫做期望值思維
什麼叫期望值思維
意思是
你不需要知道
一件事情
一定會發生
你只需要知道
它發生了 我賺多少？
它沒發生 我虧多少
它發生的機率
大概是多少
我舉一個
貼近生活的案例
假如你走在路上
被一個富豪攔下
他問你
你想要直接
拿到一張100元
還是跟他玩個遊戲
你的勝率只有
1%
但只要贏了
就能賺100萬元
大多數人
都會選第一個
因為第一個
你確定能拿到
但如果
你能跟富豪玩100次
你會選擇哪一個
這時候
你是不是猶豫了
玩100次
按照機率
應該會贏一次
贏一次
就有100萬了
給你100張百鈔
加起來只有一萬
玩遊戲
肯定是更好的選擇
這就是期望值
你明明在股市裡
有超過千百萬次機會
只要你
每一次的投資決定
都站在期望值高的那邊
你絕對能賺到
數不盡的財富
但大多數人
只把眼前的決定
當做人生
唯一的投資決定
於是
你不允許自己賠錢
告訴自己
股票只要不賣
就不算賠
你只要等到它漲回來
就能賺到錢了
你就把你的時間
全部浪費在上面
也因此
你再也沒有優勢
勝過股市裡
其他玩家了
所以說
真正投資賺錢的人
其實不是預言家
而是精算師
他們不會把
唯一的優勢
全押在
某一局的勝負
而是讓它發揮
期望值的效果
把投資從一場賭局
變成一門
機率的生意
在台股這個市場裡
我們這樣
本金少少的普通人
到底應該用什麼方法
建立自己的投資系統
才能把這部影片的概念
從理論
落地到實際操作
我有一場
免費的線上講座
專門為新手小白設計
裡面會分享
我自己實戰十多年
到現在還在用的
當沖七大獲利術
以及兩種
高勝率的選股方法
幫你找到
正要飆漲的股票
並制定完整的
進出場策略
現在到資訊欄點連結
就能免費報名
講座的名額有限
如果你點進去
看不到場次
代表暫時額滿了
投資這件事
表面上是金融問題
底層其實是
自我認知的問題
你有多了解自己
你對自己的弱點
有多誠實
這些能力
沒有任何一本教材
會教你
但這一切
都有一個起點
你得先搞清楚
你在這場遊戲裡
扮演什麼角色
我是小王子
我們下次見